[Music]
I grew up spending so much time in the
ocean it's like the only thing I would
draw as a kid just draw a perfect little
right-hand Point Break every time it
just becomes almost the same thing you
can just flip it out and it's kind of
it's everything for our family it's
where we go to just goof around and have
fun with the kids when their friends are
over and then it's also we're all ghosts
sometimes alone just to be with my
father you know he's not with us anymore
but I feel this presence when I'm in the
ocean it's uh it's something that we
spent so much time together in the ocean
that now when I'm there it's the place I
feel closest to him so it's a spiritual
place for me
[Music]
but we really have to ask ourselves do
we want to keep making things that are
meant to be used for a second and then
laughs in the ocean forever and so you
know it gets there lots of different
ways sometimes it's intentional and
stumped off a boat but more often than
not it's blowing out of a landfill or
so much of what we're producing is
ending up in the ocean it's a good
reminder to look and to say is a very
blue beautiful ocean - still you know I
mean it's there's so much hope when you
just look at all the beauty the dolphins
riding the bow this morning the birds
that keep staying right along with us
and just landing with us there one smile
and every time they drift to certain
distance back they pick up their wings
and they start flying again they come
and hang out for a while and just
getting experience those things I mean
that does so much more than finding the
negative sometimes you know let's say
you see all these things and it makes
you want to do whatever you can to keep
this ocean as beautiful for generations
to come as you can
[Music]
fragments on the sea birds of prey a
[Music]
little time machine messages of love and
hey why can't we relate with ourselves
with what we've opened up
is too late fragments of a scene
[Music]